la seule chez sega cinquième génération
de réseaux mobiles jusqu'à 100 fois plus
rapides que notre actuel 4g la promesse
d'une quasi instantanéité lors d'une
connexion
concrètement cela ouvre à la traduction
simultanée
la multiplication des objets
interconnecté où l'avenir de la
robotique
vous pourrez peut-être bientôt regarder
ses cages dans une telle définition que
vous pourrez voir jusqu'où petit cheveu
du kram d'olivier de la marche est tué
dire quelle europe c'est la 5 g passe
par des ondes à haute fréquence peu
utilisé jusqu'à présent essentiellement
par l'armée mais qui vont être ré
attribuées aux opérateurs plus la
fréquence des ondes est haute plus avec
son rapide mais moins leur surface
d'émission est large forçant donc la
multiplication des antennes relais pour
leur diffusion
selon une étude du cabinet ihs hs markit
la 5g pourrait rapporter 3600 milliards
de dollars et 22,3 millions d'emplois
dans le monde d'ici 2035
en france ce serait 124 milliards de
dollars et 448 mille emplois mais
qu'est-ce qu'on prépare en tout cas
et là tu es bien est elle alors qu'elle
soit 48 emplois vous oubliez tout de
suite et des inquiétudes prévoir la
croissance qu'on voit dans l'année
prochaine
pensez même pas de ces chiffres sont
exacts se pose aussi la question d'un
éventuel danger pour la santé l' agence
nationale de sécurité sanitaire a pointé
dans un rapport le manque d'informations
voir ou quasi opacité sur les
conséquences sur le long terme d'une
exposition à ces ondes 5 g/l à super
avec des chiffres comme ça encore assez
dangereux ou peut-être pas on n'en sait
rien je me le faire et papy géré la
tuerait dit à tom